since the beginning of Star Wars fans
have grown to love and hate both the
Jedi and the Sith but there is a much
wider Galaxy out there with Force users
here are some of the best
although the Jedi Order stresses
maintaining balance and the force it
traditionally favors the light side
which promotes defense passivity and
peace over dark traits like fear anger
and hatred however other Force sensitive
beings truly are all about balance one
such being is bendu an ancient being
introduced in a Star Wars Rebels third
season episode steps into Shadow a force
sensitive entity who lives on the planet
of artalon bendu claims to represent the
center of the force residing between the
lights and dark sides refusing to take
sides in any conflict bendu has still
accumulated vast knowledge of the force
over many years although bendu claims
not to interfere in the Affairs of the
Jedi or the Sith he does aid for
sensitive beings including Jedi Knight
Kanan Jairus after Kanan loses his sight
in a battle the imbalance he feels
awakens bendu not only does bendu teach
Kanan to use his other senses to
compensate for his lost sight but he
also counsels Kanan on his fears about
losing his Apprentice Ezra Bridger to
the dark side died bendu continues
providing counsel to both Kanan and Ezra
in later episodes what he seems largely
benevolent he's also fiercely neutral
and even claims it may be the will of
the force to destroy the Jedi Star Wars
often focuses on stories of good versus
evil but bendy reminds audience says
that there are always Shades of Gray in
between
a shaman and the clam murder of the
night sisters of dathomir mother
thousand occupies an unusual place in
the force at first it seems like she was
affiliated with Darth Sidious who
promises to trade Dark Side secrets with
her instead Sidious of Doug's thousand's
son Maul and trains him as a Sith Lord
thousand seeks revenge against the Sith
eventually using her Magics to resurrect
Maul and Empower his brother Savage
oppress so they could battle Sidious
these Feats cause her to lose her
physical body yet she survives as a
spirit and continues affecting events on
the physical plane even after she's
permanently destroyed more than the
other she'd helped continue fighting in
the Clone Wars and Beyond interestingly
Towson claims not have a natural
connection to the force although the
Knight sisters derive their power from
the Dark Side her abilities are based on
dafa mere style dark magics allowing her
to use a former Force lightning see the
future through a crystal ball and
transform others most notably when she
gives more a new pair of mechanical legs
well she undoubtedly uses a dark side
Urban deaths are against the Sith makes
her a very different player in Star Wars
power struggles
when it comes to choosing the most
notable Jedi several candidates come to
mind Jedi Master Yoda trained Jedi
Knights for centuries Obi-Wan Kenobi was
one of the Jedi order's most
accomplished Knights however Luke
Skywalker the focus of the original
trilogy stands out as the most
significant Jedi of his time what's
remarkable about Luke is that he often
walks alone on his journey toward
becoming a Jedi although he receives
training from both Obi-Wan Kenobi and
Yoda and studies texts left by Jedi
Masters from previous eras the Jedi are
largely extinct by the time Luke begins
his training requiring him to learn in
unconventional ways this no doubt
influences his scrappiness determination
nobility and power the Republic's Jedi
Order fell before Luke's birth largely
because of the Jedi's hubris casting
doubts on their teachings and morals
Luke also allows himself to be guided by
the force itself rather than one teacher
which allows him to become a very
different type of Jedi although he
favors peace and serenity he's not
afraid to tap into his darker emotions
as we see in his more aggressive
fighting style in the Mandalorian season
2's episode the rescue or in his fight
against Darth Vader in Return of the
Jedi at his best he's one of the most
balanced Jedi Masters and can attain
almost unbelievable levels of power
through his connection to the force
there's a reason why he's known as The
Chosen One having been both Jedi Knight
and Sith Lord Anakin Skywalker walks a
path that while devastating ultimately
is drawn by the will of the force his
incredibly High midichlorian count gave
him incredible potential and helps him
achieve Mighty Force Powers yet his
early life as a slave coupled with the
Jedi orders and ability to understand
him made him very unstable your slave
I'm a person and my name is Anakin
ultimately Anakin's distress of the Jedi
desire for power and fear of losing his
loved ones cause him to fall to the dark
side and become Darth sidious's
Apprentice Darth Vader a battle with
Obi-Wan Kenobi leaves him stripped of
much of his power yet even then he shows
he was still obeying the will of the
force by destroying both the old Jedi
Order and eventually the Sith in Return
of the Jedi two institutions that invade
his time no longer bring balance to the
force in the process he allows his son
Luke to bring about a new Jedi Order
potentially better suited for its time
as I says Lord Darth Vader is utterly
ruthless and consumed for self-loathing
although he's able to find Redemption by
killing Darth Sidious and living on his
Anakin Skywalker's Force ghost his
journey is filled with pain and
suffering showing that the force can be
quite violent in its attempts to bring
balance
The Apprentice of Anakin Skywalker
Ahsoka Tano has been many things over
her lifetime initially it looked like
she would become a member of the Jedi
Order training as a Padawan under Anakin
and serving as a general during the
Clone Wars however Ahsoka becomes
disillusioned by the Jedi Order and
leaves after being falsely accused of
committing crimes she spends several
years traveling Incognito before
resurfacing as the agent fulcrum in Star
Wars Rebels to Aid the emerging Rebel
Alliance later still she strikes out on
her own again in Adventures we'll see in
the upcoming Ahsoka Disney plus series
although people like the Mandalorian
refer to Ahsoka as a Jedi Ahsoka has
made it very clear that she does not
associate herself with the Jedi Order
anymore nevertheless she continues to
practice her Jedi skills and wields two
white lightsabers signifying her
affiliation with neither Jedi nor Sith
while she continues to help those in
need and offer counsel to Jedi like Luke
Skywalker at the end of the day Ahsoka
is one force sensitive individual who
defies classification
a member of Yoda's unnamed species grogu
is affiliated with many groups raised in
the Jedi Temple before the events of the
Mandalorian grogu had been trained by
many Jedi Masters and had tremendous
Force potential however his path to
becoming a Jedi was cut short when Order
66 caused clone troopers to exterminate
most of the Jedi Hidden Away by an
unknown benefactor grogu is eventually
found and protected by din jarin the
Mandalorian who comes to care for him
like a son more than Mandalorian helps
grogu reunite with the Jedi the child
eventually decides this path is not for
him forced to choose between a life of
the Mandalorian or a life of the Jedi by
Luke Skywalker Drogo chooses to reunite
with denjarin who looks like he'll train
grogu in the ways of the mandalorians in
the mandalorians season 3. if Kroger
does indeed decide to use his force
abilities as a Mandalorian foundling he
won't be the first one the legendary tar
vizla was a force sensitive Mandalorian
who was inducted into the Jedi Order he
crafted the darksaber a weapon that came
to signify the rule of Mandalore
although Luke claims grogu could only
live as a Mandalorian or a Jedi it's
still very possible grogu can do both
members of Yoda species live centuries
meaning the 50 year old influence has
many different career paths in his
future
the inquisitors offer a way for the Sith
order to work around the rule of two
established by Darth Bane always do
there are no more no less
a master and an apprentice although the
rule stipulates that I can only be two
Sith at one time there are still many
Dark Side users in the galaxy and Sith
laws like Darth Sidious seek to exploit
them this leads to the creation of the
inquisitors for sensitive agents touched
by Palpatine with the job of hunting
down any Jedi who survived Order 66 many
of these inquisitors are former Jedi
themselves including a power one Jedi
Temple guard who's four allegiance to
the dark side and became the grand
Inquisitor as the leader of the other
inquisitors the grand Inquisitor answers
directly to Darth Vader while he isn't a
Sith Lord the grand Inquisitor functions
as a parallel to Darth Vader much like
Anakin Skywalker the grand Inquisitor
fell to the dark side after becoming
resentful of the Jedi Order did not
share its secrets with him he also
regularly deceives and betrays his
fellow inquisitors including the third
sister Riva who sought to usurp his
title in Obi-Wan Kenobi showing that the
worst Dark Side users didn't have to be
Seth a member of the guardian of the
will a religious order that promotes
Unity with the force the blind Warrior
monk chirot imway is a devout believer
in the force although he isn't a Jedi
turret appears to be Force sensitive and
can use the force to perceive his
surroundings and accomplish miraculous
Feats in Rogue one a Star Wars story he
takes out an entire gang of
Stormtroopers using only a wooden stick
blows a ship out of the sky with his
light bow and walks through a firefight
without getting hit by a single Blaster
shot although he dies in a subsequent
explosion turret also feels a force
around certain objects and beings he can
sense a Kiva Crystal the power source of
a Jedi's lightsaber around in erso's
neck later he feels the force moving
Darkly around Cassian Andor and
correctly predicts Cassian is preparing
to assassinate someone while his powers
appear low level compared to the more
exotic abilities of the Jedi and the
Sith chew its faith in the force is
unshakable and he willingly submits
himself to its will up to his death
as a daughter of Anakin Skywalker and
the sister of Luke Skywalker Princess
Leia Organa possesses the potential to
wield Force Powers unlike her father and
brother however Leia chooses not to
follow the path of the Jedi opting
instead to lead Freedom Fighters as a
general that's not to say that Leia has
a manifested force abilities or that
she's incapable of tapping into her
innate Powers even as a child Leia is
able to resist an Inquisitor mind probe
in Obi-Wan Kenobi a feat she replicates
as a young adult in Star Wars Episode 4
A New Hope her resistance to the mind
probe is considerable it'll be some time
before we can extract any information
from her she also has an instinctive
connection to her brother Luke and can
sense his presence and The Empire
Strikes Back and guide the Millennium
Falcon back to him in the rise of
Skywalker we learned that Leia had been
trained by Luke but stopped after
believing her some would die at the end
of her Jedi path nevertheless Leia still
uses her Jedi abilities to survive in
battle after being blown out to space
and later manifests as a force ghost
along with Luke some may feel that
someone with her degree of force
potential should be a Jedi yet Leia
invariably charts her own course
older than even Jedi Master Yoda Mars
Kanata is over a thousand years old by
the beginning of the force awakens
although she tells Rey I am no Jedi but
I know the force Mars is force sensitive
and has knowledge of the force this
enables her to charge her own path and
be a largely benevolent being who still
has no problem dealing with the skimmier
folk in the Star Wars Galaxy indeed Mars
gains a reputation as a pirate Queen
hosting traveling Smugglers and
criminals at her castle which resembles
a somewhat cleaner version of tatooine's
mos Eisley Cantina it's not surprising
that she develops her friendship with
Han Solo or refers to his first mate
Chewbacca as her boyfriend nevertheless
Mars follows her own code prohibiting
any of the criminals who sought
Sanctuary at a home from engaging in
politics war or fighting Mars's role in
the story lies in their talents for
collecting Antiques and treasures from
across the Galaxy many of these items
speak to her through the force letting
her know which Relic she needs to
protect and Safeguard but secretly
Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber which was
passed down to Luke by Obi-Wan Kenobi
which he then passes on to Rey Mars's
long lifespan and ability to safely
navigate through the criminal underworld
make her the ideal Guardian for Jedi
relics and other forgotten Treasures
while her reverence for the force
ensures his items go to the right owners
in time